coucou comment ça va aujourd'hui on se
parle de ce smartphone là et ce
smartphone là c'est le oppo Renault 8 et
au moment où je vous en parle le
smartphone n'est pas encore annoncé
n'est pas encore sorti donc surtout
c'est un smartphone je suis en train de
filmer avec tout de suite je suis en
train de filmer en 4K en 30 images par
seconde et ça c'est bien comme ça on
commence vraiment à se mettre dedans
alors aujourd'hui on fait quoi
aujourd'hui on va regarder ce au porino
8 de tous les côtés parce que pour
annoncé trois nouveaux smartphones 8 il
est là fait le 8 Lite le petit frère et
le réseau 8 Pro le grand frère nous on
se concentre sur le frère du milieu
aujourd'hui le Renault 8 5G on va
regarder s'il est bien on va regarder
s'il est fait pour vous on va regarder
ce qu'il sait faire pas faire à
commencer par la photo et la vidéo vous
êtes prêts on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le réunion 8 alors le Raino 8 regarder
je vous montre très très rapidement
parce que il faut connaître déjà un peu
ce qui peut faire et ce qui peut venir
vous proposer après on parlera design
après on parlera de puissance après on
parlera de performance ça va venir soyez
tranquille rassurez-vous moi je veux
qu'on parle de ça parce que ça c'est
vachement intéressant vous avez vous le
voyez ici trois capteurs à l'arrière et
vous avez un capteur à l'avant dans ces
trois capteurs à l'arrière vous en avez
deux qui vont être vraiment intéressants
vous avez un capteur principal grand
temps que c'est un 50 mégapixels c'est
l'immx 766 tu ouvres 1.8 et en fait ça
c'est un capteur qui a été co-conçu en
partenariat avec Sony c'est à dire qu'il
y a oppo et Sonic en travaillant
ensemble pour venir développer ce
capteur donc il est totalement optimisé
c'est un capteur qu'on retrouve déjà
dans la série finit 5 du début d'année
donc c'est un super capteur qui marche
vachement bien deuxième capteur on est
sur un 8 mégapixels c'est l'ultra
grand-angle on ouvre f2.2 et la macro
c'est du 2 mégapixels en ouvrant f2.4 et
il y en a un autre qui est aussi
vachement intéressant c'est le capteur
vous allez avoir juste ici là au niveau
de la caméra de selfie c'est un 32
megapixels c'est la Sony IMX 709 qui a
été également co-conçu en partenariat
avec Sony et ici on ouvre f2.4 autant
vous dire qu'on a le fruit de la
collaboration entre Sony et oppo sur le
capteur principal arrière et sur la
caméra de selfie alors tout ça c'est
bien sur le papier maintenant on va
regarder dans les faits est-ce que c'est
dit en regardant le rendu photo on se
fait une petite balade dans Paris on est
place de la République on est sur le
capteur principal mais ça marche comme
une vachement vachement bien le ciel les
détails les teintes les couleurs la
lumière l'exposition rien n'est cramé on
a bien aussi ici toute la verdure rien
n'est sur saturé c'est extrêmement bien
maîtrisé c'est très naturel très beau
boulot ici sur ce capteur principal qui
marche bien sur un smartphone milieu de
gamme il faut quand même le préciser et
on regarde le prix dans quelques
instants on passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle on a une certaine cohérence
on voit que c'est un peu plus saturé au
niveau du ciel du ciel est quand même
bleu un peu plus foncé ça va être au
niveau des armes il y a rien qui me
choque bon voilà on passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle ça marche bien rien à
reprocher ici on peut venir zoomer un
peu alors comme on a pas que tel
objectif on va éviter de venir trop
zoomer mais si vous voulez venir zoomer
si vous voulez venir vous rapprocher
vous le ferez en X 2 au-delà après c'est
pas terrible pareil ici on a du détail
on voit bien le ciel les façades des
bâtiments quel que soit la lumière qu'on
va avoir dessus vous voyez là il y a
beaucoup de soleil là il y en a pas ça
se voit bien d'un côté comme de l'autre
donc très très belle maîtrise ici de la
part de oppo sur ces différents capteurs
là aussi c'est pareil c'est très très
bien ça marche vachement bien
franchement on a rien à reprocher à ce
smartphone là capteur principal on passe
sur l'ultra grand-angle c'est très très
bien là je vais chercher une scène un
peu plus complexe avec le soleil donc on
est sur un contre-jour pour autant et ça
c'est vachement cool je retrouve bien ma
façade qui est bien exposée celle-là qui
au soleil et bien ça ne dure pas par
rapport à celle qui est en face qui en
plus un contre-jour avec le soleil
YouTube ça va ça fonctionne donc ça
c'est cool on continue sur l'ultra grand
temps les liens c'est la même chose un
même détail ça fonctionne vraiment bien
on se balade dans Paris il y a plein de
soleil en face on est dans une petite
ruelle avec de l'ombre on a bien les
détails un peu de tous les côtés que ce
soit sur le grand angle ou l'ultra
grand-angle pareil ici au niveau des
nuages ça marche bien grand temps ultra
grand-angle bon j'ai essayé de shooter
un peu macro on peut pour s'amuser mais
très honnêtement voilà Macron de
mégapixels c'est pas un truc auquel je
crois les marques le mettent pour vous
proposer un peu plus de capteurs c'est
du marketing maintenant est-ce que c'est
bien la réponse est non on a un bon
piqué sur le grand angle sur l'ultra
grand-angle on voyait on voit une petite
différence au niveau du capteur voyez
sur la façade du bâtiment sur le grand
angle c'est beaucoup plus lumineux et
très naturel sans l'ultra grand-angle
est un poil plus foncé je sais pas dire
terme mais un peu moins bien exposé
c'est un peu la limite qu'on peut venir
retrouver caméra de selfie là je suis
vraiment venu la chercher avec le chien
dessus c'est une vraie tête de con là
dessus regardez la triple menton
par-dessous avec la caméra de selfie je
trouve qu'elle est un peu en dessous la
teinte au niveau de la peau là il y a un
côté qui est pas très naturel un peu sur
eux j'aime pas des masses et j'ai pas
venir la recommander en tout cas bien
comme ça par contre en mode portrait
bien éclairé ça marche bien c'est bien
c'est beaucoup mieux donc là vous voyez
le mode portrait avec le détourage qui
se fait tout autour ça c'est aussi très
très bien on essaye un différentes
choses toujours avec le mode portrait
mode portrait également mais le mode
portrait là on a 2 jours on peut
également l'avoir de nuit sur la photo
de nuit vous allez voir les choses sont
un peu différentes déjà ça sera un peu
moins bon niveau de la gestion des
lumières qu'on va retrouver ici au
niveau des lampadaires et vous allez le
voir ce qu'on va venir se balader vous
voyez ici c'est déjà un peu plus
compliqué il est un peu plus de mal et
surtout ce qu'on va retrouver c'est que
on a aucune stabilisation optique et
comme on a aucune stabilisation optique
surtout avec moi ça pardonne pas que
j'ai un tremblement essentiel et bien
voyez c'est tout de suite beaucoup moins
net et les photos de nuit en mode
portrait que vous allez voir juste après
j'avais posé sur un trépied c'est la
raison pour laquelle ça bougeait pas
c'était parfait mais dès que vous le
tenez à la MEC vous allez vous balader
si vous bougez un peu et bien tout de
suite ça pardonnera pas mode portrait de
nuit qui fonctionne aussi bien alors de
nuit il y a encore un peu de lumière
mais je suis venu faire comme si vous
aviez un éclairage de nuit avec eux le
néon sur le côté pour autant ça marche
bien d'un côté ça détour bien pareil ici
ça fonctionne bien là on se parle de la
photo mais il y a également de la vidéo
pour venir filmer jusqu'en 4K 30 images
par seconde je peux venir faire de la
vidéo de nuit la vidéo de lui tout ce
qui est le plus standard là je suis en
4K à 30 fps et si je veux je peux même
avoir le mode vidéo portrait par contre
si je passe en vidéo portrait je passe
en 1080p donc là je commence avec un
flou de base je suis à F4 mais je fais
descendre plus bas prenez en rajouter
encore un peu plus de flou en
arrière-plan là je suis à F28 c'est un
flou qu'on vient de proposer par défaut
ça vient de flouter un peu tout ce qu'il
y a autour de moi et globalement ça fait
le taf je peux descendre jusqu'à F14 le
problème de F14 c'est que dès que vous
bougez ça va se voir parce que d'un
point de vue purement logiciel c'est un
flou logiciel il va avoir un petit peu
plus de mal retour à F de 8 la limite
n'a pas du truc c'est pour les gens un
peu comme moi qui bougent qui parlent
avec les mains et bien là ça va venir se
perdre un petit peu le flou va être un
peu plus compliqué donc si vous bougez
beaucoup si vous parlez avec les mains
si vous n'êtes pas très stable et
toujours un peu une armée un peu comme
moi c'est un peu le bazar mais surtout
la vidéo en mode portrait ça marche
beaucoup mieux lorsque vous avez de la
lumière lorsque vous êtes en plein jour
et là ça sera vraiment bien donc là je
suis à F de 8 on peut venir moduler
également et descendre un petit peu F14
après c'est vous qui voyez vous le
réglez comme vous voulez d'ailleurs je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez
dites-le-moi en bas en commentaire
ça c'est la couleur noire il existe
également en couleur or surtout le dos
que vous avez là c'est de l'opoglo alors
l'opoglo c'est pas une matière qui est
nouvelle pour trouver quelques reflets
qui sont assez sympas alors autre truc
là vous avez effectivement la marque là
qui revient à sortir et puis surtout le
truc est vraiment intéressant et on le
voit on l'avait déjà vu avec le finding
5 Pro et puis même avant et bien c'est
que là en fait tout le dos il est fait
d'un seul et même bloc et ça c'est très
cool parce que oppo nous fait un très
joli travail donc vous avez vraiment
tout un module tout en sachant que vos
objectifs sont protégés par un verre
Corning Horia glace 5 donc ça c'est
quand même plutôt rassurant et vous avez
également un Corning Gorilla Glass 5 au
niveau de la face avant alors comme on
est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme on
va retrouver un petit menton sur le bas
qui va être juste ici après on a le
petit contour la petite caméra bon vous
voyez le design c'est très simple le
petit bouton pour venir l'allumer sur le
côté le bouton de volume vous allez
avoir votre tiroir de carte SIM qui se
trouve juste là de la recharge tout en
sachant qu'ici vous pouvez mettre une
double nano SIM et surtout de l'opoglo
avec un traitement oléophobie car le
truc que j'aime bien ici c'est que ce
smartphone je trouve pas très lourd il
se prend très bien normal il est pas
très épais en fait donc ça c'est
vraiment un point extrêmement fort par
rapport à beaucoup de smartphones qui
viennent un peu mastoc parce que bien
que vous aviez une dalle de 6,43 pouces
et bien la prise en main est bonne on
fait le tour on tient bien ça c'est très
très cool et si vous êtes balaise vous
arriverez même à faire tenir à la
verticale bon faut quand même faire
attention puisque je vous parle de
l'écran on est ici sur une dalle à
molette 6/43 pouces vous l'ai dit c'est
du Full HD plus à 409 pixels par pouce
on est sur un ratio 20/9 et surtout ici
on a un taux de rafraîchissement de 90
Hertz c'est uniquement 90 Hertz donc
c'est vous qui venez faire votre choix
vous êtes soit en 90 Hertz élevé vous
allez venir consommer davantage au
niveau de la batterie soit vous restez
en standard vous êtes en 60 à vous de
voir ce que vous préférez tout en
sachant qu'ici c'est un écran qui n'est
pas certifié à Julien 10 plus à savoir
qu'ici vous avez juste en haut parleur
mono c'est le haut-parleur qui se trouve
sur le côté si vous le Bouchez il y a
pas de son ailleurs donc je vous
conseille pour toute l'expérience
multimédia de venir utiliser des
écouteurs et pourquoi pas des enco X2
qui vous sont d'ailleurs offert avec ce
smartphone s'il vous intéresse ça c'est
jusqu'au 14 septembre c'est sur le
lancement une fois qu'il sera bien parti
bien lancé il faudra venir acheter vos
enco X2 au tarif 299 €. donc autant en
profiter dès le départ et une fois de
plus si vous intéresse je vous mets un
lien juste en bas dans la description
tout en sachant que vous avez du
Bluetooth 5.3 puis plein de codec vous
avez de la pétage et de la ptxtws+ Dual
dag du lhdc Dulac du SBC bref vous en
avez plein plein de collègues de tous
les côtés donc en termes de
compatibilité il y a ce qu'il faut alors
il y a un autre sujet qui est
extrêmement intéressant sur ce
smartphone là c'est toute la question de
la performance ici on n'est pas chez
quoi comme on est chez médiathèque on
est sur un domaine City 1300 gravés en
synanomètre on est sur un processeur qui
ira très bien pour le milieu de gamme on
a 8 Go de RAM c'est l'alpdr 4x tout en
sachant que vous pouvez venir ajouter
jusqu'à 5 Go de RAM c'est la RAM
virtuelle donc soit 3 Go soit 2 giga
soit 5 Go ça veut dire transformer votre
stockage votre homme en rame ça va
dépendre de l'espace disponible dans
votre smartphone donc si vous le
surcharger maman ça marchera pas mais
bon comme par défaut vous avez 256 Go de
RAM en ufs proposant on est large
vraiment et truc intéressant ici c'est
qu'on a une fluidité qui est certifié
pendant trois ans par toy land autre
truc à connaître au niveau du
refroidissement de votre Smartphone vous
avez du graphène pour venir refroidir
beaucoup plus rapidement moi il y a un
truc qui m'intéresse beaucoup c'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir venir retrouver ici à
l'intérieur de la boîte c'est ça ça
c'est le bloc de charge et c'est pas
n'importe quel bloc de charge c'est de
la super book je sais pas si vous
connaissez oppo si vous êtes intéressé
si vous suivez beaucoup l'actu de peau
au pot ils innove énormément au niveau
de la recharge de la recharge rapide
déjà vous avez une batterie de 4500
milliampères heure en fait c'est de la
batterie de bicellulaire vous avez deux
écrit de 2250 milliampères heure mais
recharger plus rapidement bref je vous
passe un petit peu le truc mais surtout
là vous avez de la super vous que c'est
de la 80 watts ce qui fait que votre
Smartphone vous le recharger de 0 à 100%
seulement 34 minutes alors pour autant
un smartphone vous me le gardez entre le
20 et 80 % vous évitez descendre en
dessous des 20 % vous éviter de monter
au-dessus des 80 % et vous le
rechargerez vous encore plus vite ça
c'est bien et il est certifié jusqu'à
160 cycles de charges soit à peu près
d'utilisation de 4 ans vous avez de quoi
venir l'expérience logiciel on l'a connu
on en a déjà parlé c'est coloros coloros
ça marche très très bien vous avez tous
vos paramètres c'est très clair c'est
lisez vous avez plein de couleurs
différents codes comme ça on sait
exactement ce qui se passe c'est très
lisible une fois de plus c'est vraiment
une expérience qui est très chouette et
qui est en plus extrêmement
personnalisable comme on se base ici sur
un Android 12 vous avez matérial you
donc si vous voulez venir customiser
vous pouvez venir customiser avec toutes
les options que vous propose en plus là
dessus au pot il y a un truc que je vous
montrais qui est hyper hyper malin hyper
intéressant sur coloros vous venez ici
dans vos paramètres vous allez dans mot
de passe et sécurité vous allez juste
ici dans sécurité du système et vous
allez sur Demander un mot de passe pour
la mise hors tension ça peut paraître un
peu bête on va mais pourquoi est-ce que
je vais venir demander un mot de passe
lorsque je viens arrêter mon smartphone
c'est pas très logique en fait si c'est
assez logique cette histoire là parce
que imagine non que vous vous fassiez
voler votre smartphone regardez je
cherche à l'éteindre hop là éteindre
confirmer votre identité il me demande
mon mot de passe alors je veux pas
j'annule parce que je veux le garder
allumé et le truc est très malin c'est
que si quelqu'un venait vous le voler à
l'arracher qu'est-ce que fait un voleur
tout de suite il va venir l'éteindre
pour pas se faire géolocaliser ici il
peut pas l'éteindre et comme on peut pas
ni enlever de batterie ni rien et bien
le smartphone va être géolocalisable dès
lors qu'il aura de la couverture réseau
donc ça permettra de suivre votre
smartphone si toutefois vous le faites
voler si vous voulez tout savoir et
découvrir coloré je vous renvoie ma
vidéo que j'ai dû faire il y a 5 mois où
je vous présente toutes les nouveautés
comme ça vous maîtriserez un coloros
comme personne on a ici du wifi 6 du NFC
pour le paiement des matérialisé une
garantie de trois ans donc pendant trois
ans vous êtes peinard s'il y a le moins
de défauts au niveau de votre smartphone
et bien il sera pris en charge par la
garantie alors attention si vous le
Cassez c'est une garantie qu'il vous
faut c'est une assurance mais en tout
cas pendant trois ans il est sous
garanti et surtout vous avez un indice
de réparabilité de 8,2 sur 10 et c'est
un smartphone qui coûte
599 euros je vous l'ai dit jusqu'au 14
septembre vous avez les écouteurs en
cours X2 offert d'une valeur de 199
euros Verdi qu'est-ce qui raconte ce
smartphone alors moi ce oppo Renault 8
je le trouve intéressant à 599 euros en
plus avec l'offre de lancement c'est
hyper hyper canon on a des photos qui
sont très bien sur votre capteur
principal et sur l'ultra grand-angle ça
marche bien il y a aucun des deux
capteurs qui va venir à trahir la
qualité du produit qui marche bien la
caméra de selfie elle marchera bien si
vous êtes bien exposée et que vous avez
une bonne lumière donc attention on est
sur une lumière des fois un petit peu
moyenne ça sera un peu moins bien mais
si vous avez une bonne lumière ça
fonctionnera il y aura absolument aucun
problème le mode vidéo portrait je le
trouve assez marrant alors attention il
faut faire gaffe faut pas trop bouger
parce que si vous venez bouger il y a un
moment ça risque de se voir un petit peu
au niveau des épaules mais si on veut
venir ajouter un foudrière-plan sans
trop bouger ça fera le taf le mode
portrait de nuit marche bien je trouve
qu'on a un truc qui est très équilibré
bonne qualité au niveau de la photo le
truc qui me rassure aussi c'est le bloc
de recharge très rapide vous le prenez
vous le branchez vous le charger vous
êtes parti vous êtes vraiment tranquille
vous l'emmenez avec vous très facilement
donc ça aussi c'est très chouette
l'écran est de bonne qualité à 599 €, on
aurait pu s'attendre à avoir un écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de son
verre ici c'est pas du tout le la partie
prix de peau 90 Hertz c'est déjà fluide
ça marche bien donc bon en terme
d'expérience de visionnage et gaming ça
fonctionnera on a suffisamment de
performances avec le processeur
médiathèque on a donc un smartphone qui
est équilibré qui est maîtrisé qui est
bien avec une très belle expérience
logicielle ici à 599 € à vous de me dire
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire comment vous le trouvez ce
que vous avez déjà vu un smartphone de
peau un rhinoc6 6 pro l'année dernière
peut-être Renaud 7 cette année aussi
vous savez en fait la gamme rénaux
c'était demi générations en fait ils en
sorte deux parents l'année dernière à la
même période on a vu le Rainbow Six là
on a le Renault 8 on aura probablement
un Rayno neuf d'ici quelques mois et
dans un an un réno-dix donc bon tout ça
on en parlera bien évidemment
ultérieurement donc je vous invite à
venir vous abonner c'est pas déjà fait
pour tout savoir de haut pot des
produits oppo mais également de
l'actualité tech en règle générale ça
c'est cool bon d'ici là prenez soin de
vous je vous embrasse beaucoup d'amour
et puis du coeur de l'amour de la
famille et beaucoup d'amis voilà et de
l'amour beaucoup d'amour Ciao
[Musique]